bienvenue merci d'avoir choisi la pause
pour refaire votre examen l'examen d'un
quart d'heure il est 55 vous êtes tous
d'accord on peut démarrer la session
maintenant dans la concurrence passer
son code de la route avec la poste c'est
désormais possible la société a obtenu
l'agrément de l'état dans le cadre de la
réforme du permis de conduire elle met à
disposition
désormais certains de ses locaux comme
les bureaux de poste ou salles de
formation depuis janvier à saint germain
en laye un site postale dédié au passage
du code de la route est ouvert dans les
yvelines six établissements similaires
ont vu le jour à puis en cours bois
d'arcy ou encore rambouillet celui de
saint germain en laye a une spécificité
si c'est vrai c'est très particulier
puisque c'est un centre qui ne fait que
cette activité là et sinon c'est vrai il
peut être aussi intégré à une plateforme
industrielle du courrier ou dans au
siège social de différentes directions
réaliser les examens du code de la route
c'est une mission qui s'inscrit
totalement dans la stratégie de la poste
de pour se diversifier innover façon à
faciliter la vie pour tous dans ce
centre dix places sont proposées par
session l'examen se passe en deux étapes
une prise en main de la tablette est
ensuite l'épreuve cet après midi là
trois candidats étaient présents j'ai
fait le code un autre endroit une
première fois et j'ai pas vraiment aimé
c'est pas dans un endroit très
chaleureux va dire que j'ai recherché à
un autre endroit
qui avait l'air meilleure et j'ai
regardé trouver la poste et ça m'a paru
bien donc je suis venu c'est mes parts
on voit qu'ils ont inscrit je ne suis
pas très loin d'ici donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aller à celui ci ait choisi
la poste parce que comme ça j'ai pas
besoin d'y aller tout le temps de me
déplacer je peux le faire de chez moi
donc c'était plus pratique les candidats
ont leurs résultats sur leur téléphone
en 30 à 40 minutes c'est aussi un
nouveau métier pour les agents de postes
après avoir été pendant 18 ans facteur
depuis deux mois je
gérais choisissent
cette voie suite des ennuis de santé
mon directeur m'a proposé ce poste et
j'ai fait une immersion pendant deux
semaines et puis formation formation
internet et puis ensuite sur le terrain
en ile de france 70 sites postaux
propose de passer l'examen du code de la
route